with less concern about the molar report
president Trump is turning his attention
to the national emergency he declared at
the southern border mr. Trump threatened
drastic action against Mexico as early
as next week
if Mexican authorities did not stop
illegal border crossings including
possibly president Trump has said a
border shut down a major closing of the
border could threaten five million
American jobs and cost billions of
dollars in trade goods but the US says
border patrol officers are overwhelmed
with a dramatic increase in asylum
seekers Kenneth Craig is here with more
details Kenneth good morning good
morning to you Tony as president Trump
takes a victory lap over the Moller
report he's promising again to shut down
the US border with Mexico to stem the
flow of undocumented immigrants so
there's a very good likelihood that I'll
be closing the border next week the
president renewed his threat yesterday
to shut down the flow of people and
goods across the southern border he
called on congressional Democrats to get
tougher on immigration and demanded that
Mexico stop undocumented immigrants from
entering the u.s. they're gonna stop
them and if they don't stop them with
closing the border they'll close it that
look we'll keep it closed for a long
time I'm not playing games the threat
comes as the Department of Homeland
Security says the number of undocumented
immigrants in their custody is at a
crisis level with holding facilities
overflowing mostly with families and
children DHS secretary Kirsten nielsen
wrote to Congress that we face a
system-wide meltdown and agents have
been forced to begin releasing large
numbers of aliens into the United States
she says her greatest concern is for the
children who are arriving sicker than
ever before there are at least 6600
families in custody and approximately
4,700 children in El Paso Texas alone
32,000 migrants have made their way into
the city this year that's up from 30,000
in all of 2017 and 2018 combined Customs
and Border Patrol Chief Kevin McHale
enon visited the city on Wednesday the
increase in family unit
is a direct response to the
vulnerabilities in our legal framework
for migrants and smugglers know that
they will be released and allowed to
stay in the US indefinitely it's a big
fat con job folks at a campaign rally
Thursday night in Michigan President
Trump said those seeking asylum in the
US were not actually facing persecution
at home and he renewed a familiar call
walzwerk folks we need the wall
Democrats say it's the administration
that is responsible for the crisis
through its failed policies of
separating and incarcerated families and
focusing too narrowly on a wall instead
of comprehensive immigration reform
Michelle Kenneth thank you well